spinal fusion is performed on the spine
- well two or more vertebrae together
using surgical hardware and bone graft
material
the spine consists of a series of
interconnected Bones called vertebrae
extending from the base of the skull to
the tailbone
each vertebra connects with a one above
and below at the facet joints allowing
them to move relative to one another
in between each bony vertebra lies a
shock absorbing intervertebral discs the
facet joints and intervertebral discs
work together to permit the bending and
twisting motions of the back and neck
protected within the vertebral column is
the spinal cord which connects the brain
to the rest of the body spinal nerves
emanate from the spinal cord at regular
intervals your doctor may recommend
spinal fusion if you have one of the
following conditions a fractured
vertebra excessive motion between
vertebrae causing instability and pain
spondylosis a degenerative arthritis
condition that may cause loss of normal
spinal structure and function or
spondylolisthesis a condition in which
one vertebra slips forward relative to
the one next to it other conditions that
may require surgery include
osteoarthritis of the facet joints a
spinal deformity such as scoliosis or
kyphosis or a bulging or herniated disc
which can press on the exiting spinal
nerve
spinal fusion is designed to eliminate
movement between the affected vertebrae
making the spine more stable and
decreasing pain before your procedure an
intravenous line will be started a
catheter may be placed in your bladder
to drain your urine spinal fusions are
done under general anesthesia which
means you will be asleep for the
duration of the operation
a breathing tube will be inserted
through your mouth and into your
windpipe to help you breathe during the
procedure if your surgeon is using your
own bone for the fusion he or she will
make an incision overlying your hip and
remove a bone graft if your bone graft
is coming from another donor it will be
harvested prior to your procedure if
you're having an open procedure on the
lumbar spine in your lower back you will
lie on your stomach and your surgeon
will make an incision directly over the
spine if you are having surgery on the
cervical spine in the neck your surgeon
will generally approach this area from
the front in some cases a spinal fusion
may be performed using a newer less
invasive laparoscopic technique rather
than one or two large incisions a
laparoscopic spinal fusion requires
several tiny keyhole incisions through
which the laparoscope and special
surgical instruments are inserted
using a high-speed drill and other
instruments your surgeon will remove the
disc between the two vertebral bodies to
be fused
next your surgeon will insert the bone
graft into the space between these two
vertebrae
he or she may also place a plate and
screws over the graft to hold the
vertebrae together until they fuse into
one bone to complete the procedure your
surgeon will close the deep tissue and
skin incision with stitches many
surgeons will also place one or more
drains beneath the skin that will remain
in place for a few days after your
procedure you'll be taken to a recovery
area for monitoring the bladder catheter
will likely remain in place for several
days you may be unable to eat for a day
or two after surgery and will receive
fluids and nutrition through the IV some
pain is expected during the first few
days following surgery and you will be
provided with pain medication to control
it